Туристи, що нині приїжджають у Гельсінкі,
опиняються в засніженому місті з температурою близько нуля,
тож вони залюбки заходять погрітися й випити
чогось гарячого в ресторан, що належить Сіні Марттінен.
Вона була однією з 2000 безробітних, які взяли участь
в експерименті з виплатою безумовного базового доходу у Фінляндії.
- Безумовний базовий дохід дав мені певну свободу.
Найбільше він подіяв психологічно, коли ти знаєш,
що маєш два роки, тобі платять щомісяця 560 євро,
і ти щось повинен зробити з цими грошима.
Жінка мала можливість випробувати різні професії
і врешті решт відкрила цей ресторан.
Цю свободу пошуку себе дав їй безумовний базовий дохід.
- Звісно, математики повинні будуть порахувати,
чи ми зможемо собі дозволити таку систему, але
я не думаю, що стара або чинна система соцзабезпечення дешевша.
Чинна система у Фінляндії виглядає так:
безробітні, хоча й отримують допомогу від держави,
але не мотивовані заробляти більше,
ніж передбачає соцзахист, розповідає Томас Мурая
- також учасник фінського експерименту.
- Якщо ти офіційно безробітний, ти не маєш права
багато працювати. Але експериментальний
базовий дохід дозволяв заробляти, скільки хочеш,
і отримувати безумовний дохід.
Зараз, коли повернулася бюрократія,
я маю ретельно обирати, чим мені займатися, щоб не втратити пільги.
Така система багатьох демотивує шукати роботу.
Часто безробітними стають низькокваліфіковані працівники.
Іноді, якщо вони знаходять якусь роботу, то
заробляють не більше, ніж їм і так дає держава.
Це величезне навантаження на систему
соціального забезпечення, вважають прихильники безумовного базового доходу.
Потреба змін назріла і у ФРН. Щоправда,
експериментують тут не на державному рівні.
Німецька ініціатива "Мій базовий  дохід" збирає
гроші шляхом краудфандингу, тобто через пожертви людей.
Як тільки назбирують 12 тисяч євро, необхідні,
щоб людина упродовж року могла просто так
отримувати 1000 євро щомісяця, базовий дохід
розігрується в лотерею. Так у Німеччині гроші
вже отримали 286 осіб. Утім, для ініціаторів це більш, ніж лотерея.
- Ми бачимо, що цифрова епоха змінює майже все:
як ми працюємо, як функціонує наша система
охорони здоров’я, мобільність тощо. Лише державна
соціальна система залишається незмінною,
тож безумовний базовий дохід, як на мене, міг би
стати належним розвитком соціальної держави,
модель якої походить ще з ХХ століття.
Через перехід економіки на цифрові технології
та розвиток штучного інтелекту люди дедалі більше
втрачатимуть робочі місця. Передусім це стосується
людей із низьким рівнем освіти. За прогнозами
експертів, безробіття незабаром стане величезним
навантаженням для соціальної системи. Утім,
чи є безумовний базовий дохід рішенням проблеми,
доведеться ще з'ясувати. У Фінляндії
на оцінку результатів експерименту взяли 2 роки - до кінця 2020-го.
У Німеччині експеримент ще триває.
Одне можна вже сказати точно:
усі учасники експерименту в Фінляндії , які
отримували безумовний базовий дохід,
значно щасливіші та здоровіші, ніж інші безробітні.
Вони без стресу шукали роботу і не хапалися
за першу-ліпшу. Хоча, порівняно
з іншими безробітними, ці пошуки не були більш успішними.